NOT -- WELL WE HAVE A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
I'M SORRY.
QUENTIN, THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US.
I'M SORRY TO CUT YOU SHORT.
WE WANT TO TELL YOU THIS.
THIS SHOW ISN'T LEARNING
TONIGHT, THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT, THAT WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF
STAFF CHIEF OF STAFF
GENERAL JOHN KELLY MAY BE
PREPARING TO LEAVE HIS JOB,
LIKELY VERY SOON.
KELLY IS AN HONORABLE AND
CAPABLE MAN, ONE OF THE MOST
IMPRESSIVE EVER TO ALL THAT
POST.
MANY WILL BE SAD TO SEE THEM GO,
ME INCLUDED.
THE QUESTION IS, WHO REPLACES
HIM?
MICK MULVANEY IS ALWAYS ON
BUDGET MATTERS BUT DOES HE AGREE
WITH THE PRESIDENT ON
IMMIGRATION ISSUES, THAT'S NOT A
SMALL THING.
THAT OUGHT TO BE AN ABSOLUTE
REQUIREMENT FOR THAT JOB.
WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF.
ALSO ON THE LIST, WE ARE
HEARING, HIS FORMER AIDE, HOPE
HICKS.
HOPE HICKS IS YOUNG AND
RELATIVELY PRESS SHY.
BUT IN A WHITE HOUSE WRITTEN BY
FACTIONALISM AND LEAKING, HICKS
IS MAYBE ONE OF THE FEW PEOPLE
IN WASHINGTON OR ON THE PLANET